.
POINTED TO THE D.C. CIRCUIT BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN LAST YEAR.
>> TODAY WATCHING FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY UNDERATTACK ABROAD, I AM
HERE TO FULFILL MY
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION TO PRESERVE FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
IT'S MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE
A DAUGHTER OF FORMER PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS AND A CONSENSUS
BUILDER AND AN ACCOMPLISHED
LAWYER ON ONE OF THE MOST
PRESSTIGGOUS COURTHOUSE.
I NOMINATE KETANJI BROWN
JACKSON.
JUSTICE BREYER ANNOUNCED HIS
RETIREMENT.
CHOOSING SOMEONE TO SERVE ON THE
SUPREME COURT IS ONE OF THE MOST
SERIOUS RESPONSIBILITIES THE
PRESIDENT HAS.
THE PROCESS WOULD BE VIGOROUS.
SOMEONE EXTREMELY QUALIFIED AND
A BRILLIANT LEGAL MIND WITH THE
UTMOST INTEGRITY WHICH IS
IMPORTANT.
I WOULD BRING THIS DECISION MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A LAWYER.
FORMER CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
PROTESSOR.
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR MANY YEARS AND
PRESIDED OVER MORE SUPREME COURT
NOMINATIONS THAN ALMOST ANYONE
LIVING TODAY WHICH MAKES ME 28
YEARS OLD.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I STARTED DOING IT WHEN I WAS
32.
WHO DEVOTED MUCH OF MY CAREER TO
THINKING ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE ROLE OF THE SUPREME
COURT.
WITH THAT PERSPECTIVE, I STUDIED
THE RECORD OF CANDIDATES AND
INVITED SENATORS FROM BOTH
POLITICAL PARTIES TO OFFER
POINTS OF VIEW AND MET WITH
THEM.
AS A RESULT, BECAUSE I RESPECT
NOT ONLY THE CONSENT, BUT ADVICE
AND CONSENT.
I SOUGHT THE ADVICE OF DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS.
I CONSULTED CAN LEADING SCHOLARS
AND LAWYERS AND HAD THE ADVICE
OF VICE-PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
AN EXCEPTIONAL LAWYER.
I LOOKED FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS
A PRAGMATIC UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE LAW MUST WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SOMEONE WHO HAS HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE CONSTITUTION IS A RESILIENT
CHARTER OF LIBERTY.
SOMEONE WITH THE WISDOM TO
APPRECIATE THAT THE CONSTITUTION
PROTECT RIGHTS FOR OUR MOST
PERSONAL FREEDOMS AND WITH
EXTRAORDINARY CHARACTER WHO WILL
BRING TO THE SUPREME COURT AN
INDEPENDENT MIND AND INTEGRITY
AND THE COURAGE TO STAND UP FOR
WHAT IS RIGHT.
FOR TOO LONG OUR COURTHOUSE HAVE
NOT LOOKED LIKE AMERICA.
IT'S TIME WE HAVE A COURT THAT
REFLECTS THE FULL TALENTS AND
GREATNESS OF OUR NATION.
THAT WE INSPIRE YOUNG MEMO TO
BELIEVE THEY CAN SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
I ADMIRED THESE TRAITS OF
CHARACTER AND THE JURIST
NOMINATED BY REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
TODAY I INTRODUCE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE A CANDIDATE WHO
CONTINUES IN IN GREAT TRADITION.
JUDGE JACKSON DREW UP IN MIAMI,
FLORIDA AND THE MAYOR ENDORSED
YOU.
HER PARENTS GREW UP WITH
SEGREGATION BUT NEVER GAVE UP
HOPE THAT THEIR CHILDREN WOULD
ENJOY THE TRUE PROGRAMS OF
AMERICA.
-- PROMISE OF AMERICA.
HER PARENTS WERE SCHOOL TEACHERS
AND HER MOM A PRINCIPAL AND HER
DAD REPRESENTED THE SCHOOL
BOARD.
JUDGE JACKSON FOUND HER LOVE FOR
THE LAW FROM AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MIAMI WHERE HER DAD ATTENDED LAW
SCHOOL.
SHE WOULD DRAW NEXT TO HER DAD'S
LAW BOOKS.
GREW UP TO BE A STAR STUDENT AND
ELECTED MAYOR OF HER JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL AND PRESIDENT OF HER HIGH
SCHOOL CLASS.
SHE WAS A STAND OUT ON THE
SPEECH AND DEBATE TEAM.
IT WAS AFTER A DEBATE TOURNAMENT
IN HARVARD WHEN SHE WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL SHE BELIEVED HE COULD BE
A STUDENT THERE.
SOME TOLD HER NOT TO SET HER
HEIGHTS TOO HIGH BUT REFUSED TO
SET LIMITS.
HE GO TO HARVARD AND WENT TO, TO
ATTEND HARVARD LAW SCHOOL WHERE
SHE WAS A TOP STUDENT AND
APPLIED FOR A CLERKSHIP ON THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT AND SHE WAS
SELECTED.
THE JUSTICE WAS NONE OTHER THAN
JUSTICE BREYER WHOSE SEAT I AM
NOMINATING HER TO FILL WANT NOT
ONLY DOES HE LEARN ABOUT BEING
A JUDGE FROM JUSTICE BREYER, HE
SAW THE GREAT RIGOR THROUGH
WHICH HE APPROACHED HIS WORK AND
LEARNED FROM HIS WILLING
INNOCENCE TO WORK WITH
COLLEAGUES WITH DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS.
CRITICAL QUALITIES FOR A SUPREME
COURT.
SHE STEPS UP TO FILL JUSTICE
BREYER'S PLACE ON THE COURT WITH
THE ACCOMPLISHED AND WIDE
RANGING BACKGROUND.
SHE SERVED AS A FEDERAL PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND A PRIVATE LAW
PRACTICE AS AN ACCOMPLISHED
LAWYER WITH A LAW FIRM.
IN CONFIRMED, SHE WOULD JOIN
JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR AS THE ONLY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT WHO HAS
EXPERIENCE AS I A TRIAL COURT
JUDGE AND FOLLOW IN THE FOOT
STEPS OF JUSTICE BREYER, THE
ONLY MEMBER OF THE COURT WHO
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A MEMBER OF
THE U.S. SENTENCING COMMISSION.
SHE BRINGS ADDITIONAL
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL.
COMES FROM A FAMILY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HER BROTHER AND UNCLES HAVE
SERVED AS POLICE OFFICERS.
THAT'S ONE REASON I EXPECT BY
THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE
SAID TODAY, THERE IS LITTLE
DOUBT SHE HAS THE TEMPERAMENT
AND INTELLECT AND FAMILY
BACKGROUND TO EARN THIS
APPOINTMENT.
THEY ARE CONFIDENT WE WILL
APPROACH HER FUTURE CASES WITH
AN OPEN MIND AND TREAT ISSUES
RELATED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
FAIRLY AND JUSTLY.
INCREDIBLY JUDGE JACKSON HAS
ALREADY BEEN CONFIRMED BY THE
UNITED STATES SENATE 3 TIMES.
FIRST TO SERVE ON THE U.S.
SENTENCING COMMISSION.
A BIPARTISAN COMMISSION I
DESIGNED TO REDUCE DISPARITIES
IN SENTENCING AND PROMOTE
TRANSPARENTS FOR THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
JUDGE JACKSON WAS KNOWN FOR
WORKING WITH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS TO FIND COMMON
GROUND ON CRITICAL ISSUES.
SECOND CONFIRMED BY THE U.S.
SENATE WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
TO ADMINISTER JUSTICE TO BE OVER
TRIALS.
AND THIRD ON THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA COURT.
THE SECOND MOST  HIGHEST COURT
ASIDE FROM THE EXTREMIST.
A FORMER GENERAL COUNSEL AND
GEORGIA BUSH APPOINTEE BACKED
HER AND HAILING HER LEGAL CAREER
AND BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PRACTICE.
HE WENT ON TO SAY, HER CAREFUL
APPROACH AS A TRIAL COURT JUDGE.
JUDGE JACKSON SERVICE ON THE
D.C. CIRCUIT COURT OF THE
APPEALS, 3 OF THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES ALSO SERVED FROM WHERE
SHE NOW SERVED.
HER OPINIONS ARE CAREFULLY
REASONED AND DEMONSTRATE RESPECT
FOR HOW THE LAW IMPACTS EVERY
DAY PEOPLE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN SHE PUTS HER
THUMB ON THE SCALE OF JUSTICE
BUT UNDERSTANDS THE BROADER
IMPACT OF HER DECISIONS.
SHE CARES ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
DEMOCRACY WORKS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SHE LISTENS AND LOOKS PEOPLE IN
THE HIGH.
LAWYERS AND DEFENDANTS AND
VICTIMS AND FAMILY AND MAKES
SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THE LAW AND
WHAT IT MEANS TO THEM.
SHE STRIVES TO BE FAIR, GET IT
RIGHT AND DO JUSTICE.
THAT'S SOMETHING ALL OF US
SHOULD REMEMBER AND SOMETHING I
THOUGHT ABOUT THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS.
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT WALKING OVER
HERE WITH HER.
ONE FLOOR BELOW, WE HAVE SEVERAL
DISPLAYS CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
ONE OF THEM INCLUDE THE JUDICIAL
OATH OF OFFICE TAKEN AND SIGNED
BY JUSTICE THURGOOD MARSHALL
HIMSELF.
AN OATH THAT WILL BE
ADMINISTEREDED TO
A DISTINGUISHED AMERICAN TO WRAP
THE NEXT CHAPTER IN THE JOURNEY
OF AMERICA.
HER HUSBAND PATRICK IS A SURGE
CONDOCTOR.
STAND UP AND LET THEM SEE WHO
YOU ARE.
THERE YOU GO.
THEY MET WHEN THEY WERE
UNDER-GRADUTE STUDENT AT
HARVARD.
HE IS A DISTINGUISHED CANCER
SURGEON AT GEORGE TOWN.
AND JUDGE JACKSON IS A WORKING
MON.
SHE HAD HER ELDEST CHILD WHEN HE
WAS A PRIVATE LAWYER IN
PRACTICE.
AND HER SECOND CHILD WHEN SHE
WAS ON THE U.S. SENTENCING
COMMISSION.
STAND UP.
I ASKED HER IF HE WOULD LIKE TO
BE PRESIDENT.
NO.
[LAUGHING].
YOU ARE WELCOME TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WELCOME YOUR SISTER WHO UP
IN SCHOOL IN RHODE ISLAND NOW.
I HAVE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
JUDGE, YOU ARE ALWAYS A MOM.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE NO
MATTER WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
WHETHER ARE YOUOR THE VIETNAM OR
NOT.
-- YOU ARE ON THE SUPREME COURT
OR NOT.
I HAVE A RESPECT FOR THE SUPREME
COURT AS CO-EQUAL PARTS OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
I MEAN IT.
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO NOMINATE
JUDGE JACKSON WHO WILL BRING
EXTRAORDINARY QUALIFICATIONS AND
A RIGOROUS JUDICIAL RECORD TO
THE COURT.
JUDGE JACKSON DESERVES TO BE
CONFIRMED AS THE NEXT JUSTICE OF
THE SUPREME COURT.
I MET WITH THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND SENATOR DURBIN AND
GRASSLEY.
I HOPE THEY WILL MOVE PROMPTLY
AND FAIRLY.
JUDGE JACKSO